our subject for this evening give in and
win what did i say
give in
and win let us pray
holy father in heaven
thank you father for the gift of life
thank you lord for looking after us in
so many ways and for blessing us
father so many blessings we don't even
recognize
we thank you for the holy hours in which
we now live and breathe
and for the privilege we have to come to
your presence to listen to your word
forgive our sins dear god cleanse our
hearts
and grant to us the ministry of your
holy spirit for it is he alone that can
guide us into truth
as we listen to the words of truth dear
god give us a heart willing to obey that
truth
as i humble myself before you i ask you
to use me according to your will and for
your own glory bless not only us but all
those listening over the internet be
with them father and bless them shine
the light of truth into their hearts in
jesus name we pray
amen
let me also welcome our friends
worshiping with us via the internet
wherever you are
thank you very much
for joining us
give in
and win
let's go to genesis chapter 3.
genesis chapter 3.
our overall theme is god has answers
genesis chapter 3
you shall read from verse 7.
and we're reading from the king james
version of the bible
the bible says and the eyes of them both
were opened
and they knew that they were naked and
they sort fig leaves together and made
themselves aprons and they heard the
voice of the lord god walking in the
garden in the cool of the day and adam
and his wife hid themselves from the
presence of the lord god amongst the
trees of the garden
and the lord god called into adam and
said what
where are thou
now why did god do that
why did god do that
where are thou
and he said i heard thy voice in the
garden and i was afraid because i was
naked and i
hid
myself
when adam and eve sinned
separation occurred immediately between
them and god
there was a conflict between adam and
eve and god
when god made eve from the river of adam
in genesis chapter 2 verses 21 and 22
the bible says he brought her unto the
man the man didn't run
the woman didn't run they were all
together
when god brought all the animals to adam
in verse 19 of genesis chapter 2 and god
stood by and listened as adam named
every animal adam did not run
in verse 8 of genesis 2 the bible says
and the lord god planted the garden
eastward in eden and there he put the
man whom he had formed god took adam to
his home adam did not run when god told
him in genesis 15 when the bible says in
genesis 2 15 and the lord god took the
man and put him into the garden of eden
to address it and to keep it adam did
not run
why are they running
in verse 8
because there was a problem between god
and humanity
the problem not caused by god
but caused by us
let's be honest
adam and eve
sinned against god
but the bible says
and the lord god called unto adam and
said unto him where are thou
it was god
who came calling
verse 8 of genesis 3 tells us and they
heard the voice of the lord god walking
in the garden in the cool of the day it
was god who came to fix the problem and
it was god who was innocent
the bible has a principle for human
relationships
the innocent person should move first
now that's not the way it works on the
earth
are you following me
god's way is not our way
what does isaiah 55 verse 8 say for my
thoughts
are not your thoughts neither are your
ways my ways for as the heaven is high
above the earth so are my ways higher
than your ways and my thoughts than your
thoughts the way god functions the way
god thinks is so different he compares
it to the size of the difference of the
gap between heaven and earth
and our duty as god's children is to try
to see things through god's eyes
there's a text
psalm 116 15 you know it it says
precious in the sight of the lord
is the death of his saints now listen to
the words carefully
i always ask you to read the bible
carefully precious in the sight of the
lord
is the death of his saint now i'm sure
some of you have lost a loved one maybe
i have
the death of that loved one was not
precious in your eyes
it was precious
in god's eyes
i had a brother younger brother he died
two years ago
and i was naturally sad
his death was not precious in my eyes
but how i dealt with it was to go back
to this verse
and to see his death
how
the way god saw his death because he
died knowing god
he died being right with god when i
thought of that and i realized god was
rejoicing that he could no longer be
tempted
he could no longer suffer the pain of
the cancer that he had contracted or
whatever it was he died from he could no
longer suffer the ups and downs of life
on this sinful earth he was safe
precious in the sight of the lord
is the death of his saying now who was i
to tell god don't do that
let him stay and be tempted
let him stay and possibly lose his way i
had to see it through god's eyes
listen to me carefully when you begin to
see the world through god's eyes you
change
and the way we see conflict through
god's eyes the innocent person is the
one who moves and god set that example
the one who was right
the one who was innocent
the one had done no wrong
is the one who came to fix the problem
and so we're told in romans 5 while we
were yet enemies
what happened
christ died for us
he did not wait until we were friends he
died while we were yet enemies
christ died
keeping this in mind let's go to genesis
chapter 13.
give in and win is our subject genesis
tonight i'll have to let you go close to
8 30. i hope you don't mind
oh
sister said amen did you speak for the
whole shirt sister
genesis chapter 13
we'll read from verse one
and abram went up out of egypt he and
his wife on all that he had and lot with
him into this into the south
verse 2 says and abram was very rich in
cattle
in silver
and in gold skip to verse 5 and lot
which went with abraham had flocks and
what herds
and tents
abraham had a lot of stuff
a lot a lot of stuff
verse 6 and the land was not able to
bear them that they might dwell together
for this substance was great so that
they could not dwell together god had
blessed them so much
abraham and lot had accumulated so many
cattle and
sheep and donkeys and camels whatever
else they had
that the land where they lived could not
support the two groups the two families
they were so vast they had so much
possession
verse 7 says and there was a strife
between the herdman of abram's cattle
and the herdman of lot's cattle finish
that verse
and the canaanite and the parisite dwelt
then in the land now why does the bible
say that because the non-believers were
watching
they were watching
because they knew abraham
verse 8
now abraham is aware of this strife
abraham is a godly man
abraham wants to settle this for the
sake of god's name
verse 8 of genesis 13 the bible says and
abram said unto lot let there be no
strife i pray thee between me and thee
and between my heart men and thy heard
men why
for we be brethren
what does he mean by that
we're a family
is this church a family yes or no
yes come on say yes with more life
yes
was abraham trying to solve the problem
because he was inconvenienced
no
abraham saw a larger issue
and abraham said lot
we are family more than physical we're a
family of god
we have to fix this problem for the sake
of god's name
because the canaanite and the parisite
are watching
that's what the bible tells us in first
corinthians 6
verses 1 and 2 we should not take one
another to court
where would somebody say amen
we should not take one another to court
and air our dirty laundry in public
for we be brethren
is not the whole land before thee verse
9 separate separate thyself i pray thee
from me if thou will take the left hand
then i will go to the right or without
the part of the right hand then i will
go to the left abraham comes with a
solution
for the sake
of peace
verse 10
and lord lifted up his eyes and beheld
all the plain of jordan that it was well
watered everywhere before the lord
destroys sodom and gomorrah even as the
garden of the lord like the land of
egypt as thou comest unto zoar
then lord chose him all the land of the
plain of sodom
and lord
journeyed east
abraham did something that is very noble
as we continue to subject giving and win
abraham allowed lot to choose first
which was abraham's right
because lot had left here and he
journeyed with abraham's family and then
his family grew lot came with abraham
lot was the levy of abraham abraham was
the older man abraham was in charge of
the caravan that traveled from here and
to canaan so lot was under abraham's
authority abraham has the right to
choose first
but being right is not the same thing as
being righteous
most people are always right
but seldom righteous
you know how many relationships have
been broken because somebody was right
you know how many churches have split
because somebody was right
and neither side was righteous
you know how many wars have been fought
because one side was right how many
companies have
deteriorated and gone into bankruptcy
because somebody was right
and so abraham allowed lot to choose
first
for the sake of a higher purpose than
abraham's own physical and economic
benefit
and lot greedily
notice what the bible says in verse 10
of genesis 13
and lord lifted up his eyes and beheld
all the plane of jordan that it was what
well watered
where everywhere now what does the bible
say in verse 5 of that same chapter and
lord also which went with abram had what
flocks
and herds
if you have flocks and herds what do you
need
grass and water
where it is water you'll find grass
the bible says lot lifted up his eyes
and beheld the plane of jordan that it
was well watered everywhere
before the lord destroys sodom and
gomorrah even as the garden of the lord
that's how beautiful it was physically
and lord chose sodom and gomorrah
as his place of residence
left the rocky hillsides
to abram
that was his name then it was changed to
abraham in genesis 17 verse
but abraham
suffered that indignity why
to make peace
because the bible says blessed arthur
peacemakers
there is no blessing for troublemakers
in the bible
did i say something wrong
there is no blessing in the bible for
troublemakers
now if the bible is a book of opposites
if the peacemakers are blessed
tell me about the troublemakers
oh yes
but i want you to see how god responds
to those who act on the basis of
righteousness not rightness
let's continue reading genesis chapter
12 chapter 13
we go to verse 14.
and the lord said unto abram after that
lot was separated from him lift up now
then eyes
look from the place with our northward
and southward and eastward and westward
for all the land which thou seest to
thee will i give it and to thy seed
forever
i want you to observe what god is
selling abraham
lift up now that eyes and look from the
place without
standing
northward
southward
eastward
and westward what are those four things
the cardinal points of what
the compass
the earth
god said abraham look
and all that you see what will i do
i'll give you
if you step outside to the parking lot
where's north i don't know where north
is let's call this snow uh is that north
you want to put a sign there
don't confuse the preacher all right
this is north
if you go out to the parking lot and
look north
what do you see
no you look past the trees there's
something else you see
you see the horizon you look beyond you
see the sky
then this must be south
you look this way you see the same thing
you look that way the same thing that
way the same thing what in effect was
god telling abraham to look at
the whole world
listen to me carefully god is telling
abraham i will give you the whole world
and paul makes that very clear in uh
romans chapter 4 verse 13 i believe it
is
for the promise that he would be the
heir of the world
what did lot take
the planes of jordan
what did god give ever have
everything including what lot had
because god rewards
righteous behavior
so after lord had separated from abraham
god came to him to let abraham know your
act of humility your act of self-denial
has been applauded in heaven and he said
look as far as you can look i will give
it to you and to your seed
give him
and win
it's a powerful principle because it has
its origin in heaven itself in the very
heart of god that's how god functions
the carnal nature functions the opposite
let me explain it this way here is love
and here's self
love that's god's nature self that's
ours
unconverted but we still have it even
though we're converting
the carnal nature will only be destroyed
when this mortal puts on immortality is
that clear all right
love exists
by sacrificing itself
self exists by consuming others
you miss everything
you look smart but you missed everything
let me say it again
love exists
let me say for others
what gives love
motivation and excitement is to serve
others
what excites self is to consume others
are you with me so love is a candle self
is a sponge
for god so loved the world
i will ascend into heaven
i will exalt my throne above the stars
of god i will sit also from the mount of
the congregation in the sight of the
north i will be like i will ascend above
the heights of the clouds i will be like
the most high that's me that's satan
god's ways
give in
and when
jesus christ took human form
he gave in
not to sin but to our condition
are you listening to me and he will have
it for how long
forever
this act of giving in
will be obvious to us in the new world
for all eternity because jesus christ
still has human flesh
i tell you what else he has
the marks of the crucifixion
remember luke 24 when he rose from the
grave and the disciples doubted who he
was what did he say behold my hands and
my feet it is i myself in john chapter
20 verse 20 he showed him his hands on
his side so they saw the feet they saw
the hands this on the side i guess the
broad the brow was so obvious he did not
need to show them the brow they could
see it
for all eternity
the marks that christ gave him to win us
will be evident
and we will go through heaven without a
pimple
ah you didn't hear me
what do you call them without a zit
god will have all the scars
we have nothing
because he gave in
to win
let's go to the very next chapter of
genesis genesis chapter 14.
in this chapter a war has broken out
where abraham lives
the bible says it came to pass in the
days of america king of china arya king
of eliza canoleoma king of elam and
title king of nations that these made
were with bera king of sodom and with
bersha king of gomorrah shinab king of
admira and shemiba king of zeboyam and
the king of bela which is zor
all these were joined together in the
veil of sidim which is assault sea
twelve years they served cataloomer and
in the thirtieth year they rebelled and
in the fortieth year came catelyrum and
the kings that were with him and smote
the rephaim and ashtaroth karname and
the zuzians in ham and the eminems in
shavikiri fame and the whole right in
the mount sir unto el paran which is by
the wilderness and they returned and
came to end mishpak which is kadesh and
smote all the country of the amalekites
and also the amorites that dwelt in
jesus on tamar now this is the record of
a war four kings came from across the
euphrates
to fight five kings in the area of
abraham the king of sodom gomorrah
admiral zaboy and bella
the bible says in verse 13 of genesis 14
and they came one that i escaped and
told abraham the hebrew for he dwelt in
the plain of mamre the amorite brother
of escal and brother of inner and these
were confederate with abraham or abram
as he was called them
the war was fought abraham didn't know
someone came and told him verse 14 when
abraham heard that his what
ah
his brother
but lot was really what biologically
his nephew but i told you earlier that
abraham recognized lot not so much as a
nephew but as a brother in christ
so the bible says when abraham learned
or heard his brother
let me tell you something strange
do you know your wife is your sister
do you understand what i'm saying i know
she's your wife but she's also your
sister in christ your husband is your
brother
let me leave that alone
perhaps it goes across the culture i
don't know biblically your wife is also
your sister and your husband is your
brother
when abraham heard that his brother was
taken captive he armed his trained
servants born in his own house 318 and
pursued him unto dale verse 15 and he
divided himself against them he and his
servants by night and
smoth them and pursue them unto hobart
which is on the left hand of damascus
verse 16 says and he brought what
all the goods and also brought again his
brother lot and his goods and the women
also and the people abraham brought back
everything
because verse 11 says and they took all
the goods of sodom and gomorrah and the
evictuals and went their way
verse 12 says and they took lot abram
brothers son who dwelt in uh here and in
sodom
and his goods and departed
abraham brought back everything
now look at verse 10
but the veil of syria was full of slime
pits and the kings of sodom gomorrah
fled and what
fell there when the battle began the
king of sodom and the king of gomorrah
ran and hid in these pits
what does verse 17 say and the king of
sodom did what
went out to meet abraham after his
return from the slaughter
of cathedral under kings that were with
him in the valley of sha'vi which is the
king's dale now the battle is over the
king comes out of his hole
comes to abram abram is the victor are
you with me verse 18 tells us
melchizedek comes out brings bread and
wine and he blesses abraham in 19 and
20.
in 21
the bible says the king of sodom said
unto abram what did he say
give me the persons and go on
take the goods to thyself
we're talking about giving and win
now why is the king of sodom begging
abraham
abraham had won the war
back then when you won the war you kept
everything
are you following me
the king of sodom came out of his hiding
hole
he came to this victorious man abram who
led the armies his servants and the
friends who lived nearby
and he said please
return my people so i can repopulate my
city but keep all the silver all the
gold all the wealth you keep everything
he's offering an arrangement to abram
verse 22
and abram said to the king of sodom
i have lift up my hand unto the lord
the most high god what is abraham doing
what he's saying
listen what he's saying i have lift up
my hand unto the lord
the most high god
that i will not take from a thread even
to a shoe legit and i will not take
anything that is thigh lest thou should
say i have made abram rich
now what does he mean by his lift of his
hand what is he doing
he swears to god
i am not taking
a thread
now ladies when you dress to go
somewhere and you see a thread from your
hand what do you do
you cut it off
abram said i am not taking a thread
or a shoe legend
why
i don't want the heathen to say
it's because of us that he has all that
he has
abraham is thinking of god
now abraham had the right are you
listening to me he has the right to keep
everything
he could have taken over sodom and
gomorrah because he won those kings ran
abraham said i don't want anything
he gave in
to win
the right name
for his god
now as god came to him when he gave into
lot god comes to him after he has given
in to the king of sodom in the very next
chapter chapter 15 reading from verse 1
the bible says and after these things
the word of the lord came unto abram in
the vision saying fear not abraham i am
thy shield and what else
thy exceeding now the king of sodom was
offering abraham material things
god said abram
in effect i like the decision you made
i am your
reward and when you have god what do you
have
everything
god for the second consecutive time in
back to back chapters approved the
principle of giving to win
in this hour of eighties page 89
paragraph four we write we read these
interesting words jesus
did not contend for his rights
very often his work was made
severe
because he was willing
and uncomplaining
how does isaiah say that jesus went to
the slaughter
as a lamb
giving in
to win
abraham
would have been right
to choose first ahead of lot
but for the sake of peace
he gave in
his action was righteous
a lot was wrong
now abraham gave the right a lot lot
exercised a right given to him are you
with me
but he was not righteous
abraham gave up the right
and he was righteous
and god rewarded him with the whole
world
in the very next chapter
abraham gave up a right he had won at
the risk of his life
he gave it up to a coward who ran and
hid while abraham was fighting
the very next chapter god comes and says
abraham
i
am your reward
my brothers and sisters
there's only one thing we should be
adamant about and that is truth
someone tells you let's keep
tuesday as a sabbath you've got to say
no no matter what happens come hell come
high water you've got to say no
if someone says paint the pink the pews
pink and green
you can't find a verse that says you
shouldn't do it
or quotation from testimonies volume six
are you listening to me
it's not a matter of now but that simple
thing can divide the church
i remember
many years ago when my church was
building
we had a big discussion should we put in
the air conditioning now or let's pay
off some money first then put it in
later
big discussion
people getting angry
we finally decided to put it in now and
not wait for later
and we're all happy we did but there was
a big discussion
should the carpet be brown
or no carpet at all
should we stand for the scripture
reading or sin
and people break up
because somebody's right
and nobody's righteous
my brothers and sisters god set an
example
to win
on a matter of principle
not a principle sorry to win in ordinary
irritations of life
we may have to do what
given now giving in does not hurt your
spirituality it hurts the carnal nature
ah you didn't hear me
giving in hurts the flesh
it does not hurt the spirit
because another word for giving in
is humility
i uh
in the travels the lord allows me to
make
i see this problem wherever i go
a is right
b is right
nothing happens
so you have an irresistible force coming
up against what
an immovable object and there is no
progress
it happens in churches
in businesses
in families
wherever human beings interact
we have irresistible forces up against
immovable objects the force isn't
budging the object isn't budging nothing
happens
now god could have said
i didn't sin
let adam come to me
do you know if god had decided to let
the world perish he would still have
been righteous
but he would have been
miserable if god can be miserable
whatever is close to miserable for god
he would have been miserable because
love
wants to save
love wants to redeem
love loves to build up and if god had
remained aloof i didn't do anything and
left the world to perish
he would have been miserable
love takes risks
the risk of being hurt
even when you're right
what i'm saying to you and to me
don't think i don't have to struggle
with it
i don't live in a hole
what
we have to
humble ourselves and understand that
being right is not always being
righteous
when stephen was stoned to death
in acts chapter 7 and verse 60 the bible
says and he kneeled down and cried with
a loud voice lord lay not this sin to
the charge
and when he had said this he fell asleep
now while they were stoning him
he was thinking of them
you know where he got that
matthew luke 23 34 what did jesus say
father forgive them for they know not
what they do while he was being
crucified he was praying for them
paul ii uh timothy chapter 4 verse 16 at
my first answer no man stood with me but
all men forsook me i pray god it may not
be late to their church father don't
hold them responsible they left me at
the trial by myself i was imprisoned
don't hold them responsible jesus prayed
the prayer
um stephen prayed a prayer paul prayed
and when the spirit of christ is in us
we will try our best to express and
demonstrate that attitude it is not easy
because the flesh
naturally holds its ground
but the spirit of christ is described in
philippians 2 5 onward
let this mind be in you which was also
in christ jesus
who being in the form of god fought in
the robbery to be equal with god but
made himself of no reputation and took
upon him the form of a servant and was
made in the likeness of men and being
found in fashion as a man he humbled
himself
and became obedient unto death
finish it for me even the death
of the cross
my friends at remnant sda church
message is unusual and strange and tough
all i will ask you to do is as you go
home tonight
think of what you've heard
you may be in a situation right now
where somebody needs to give in to win
it may be on the job
your family
the church
are we willing to function like christ
notice i said earlier the only thing we
don't give in on is truth
the word of god
someone says to you let's live together
we're not married you can't do that
no matter what damage it causes you
cannot do that
when someone says don't sit in that pew
it's my pew move
you know how world war one started
somebody slapped somebody
then whenever ready somebody slapped
somebody
and that started the ball rolling
give in
and when
in matthew 8 15 the bible says moreover
if thy brother offend thee go and tell
him his offense between thee and him
alone
now notice the wording if thy breathy by
brother offend thee
you
who was offended
you or i who are innocent i go
now that's tough
you only do that if the spirit of god
pushes you he pushes he doesn't shove
you see because the push must be
combined with willingness so he pushes
or he nudges but he doesn't shove
what does the bible say in matthew
chapter 5 verse 23 therefore if thou
bring thy gift to the altar which is you
come to worship and there remembers that
thy brother hath ought against thee
leave there thy gift before the altar
and go thy way first be reconciled to
thy brother and then come
what christ is saying as long as the
reconciliation is not made whatever
you're offering is unacceptable
so how many of us waste time worshipping
but there's good news the bible says in
philippians 4 13 i can do what
how
i can give him
to win
through christ
luke 18 27 the things which are
impossible with men
are possible with god
and when we yield the will to god when
we yield the will and the will is that
capacity to decide to make decisions to
say yes no
when we yield that cockpit to god and
god takes it over he sanctifies it
then gives it back to us we make godly
decisions
with that will we choose to do what's
right we choose to put aside bad habits
he gives the power we exercise the
choice
and so i say to you my brothers and
sisters from my heart with great respect
for you
with great reverence and humility i say
it from my heart
because every preacher is a sinner
every preacher needs grace the blood
that saves you saves me
and we're punished more heavily when we
sinned and you're punished
so it's not easy thing to stand in a
pulpit and preach
but having heard the message how many of
you will say lord
help me
to exercise the spirit of christ
to give in
that i may win can i see your right hand
help me help me help me just help me
stand up for me stand up
just help me
having said that
here's something i'd suggest to you
if you have something against someone
and you know it
stop planning tonight to go to that
person and try to fix it
did i speak clearly
if you know you have something against
someone
in other words you're guilty i am guilty
let's go to that person and try to fix
it
if you know someone has done you wrong
and you're innocent
let's move as god move first and try to
provide an opening for that person to
say i'm sorry
very often people who've done wrong
they're in a prison
of pride
will not say i'm sorry i mean in prison
and pride when you come as the innocent
person and say look
let's try to fix this what that does it
releases the person
so you're actually saving someone
by sacrificing your pride
so i'll ask again two things
if you've done someone something
and you know it
ask god for the strength to begin making
plans right now to go to that person and
make it right if someone has done you
wrong
ask god for the courage to go to that
person use the innocent party go and say
listen
you did me wrong but i have done wrong
in the past god has forgiven me i have
come to tell you i forgive you
i want to ask for show of hands i'll
leave it you to make those decisions
when we act like god
god responds with great joy as he
responded when abraham acted properly
regarding lot he was self-sacrificing
when abraham acted properly regarding
the king of sodom he was
self-sacrificing right after each act
god showed up
and express his approval and bless
abraham massively
let's take a risk
and the risk is doing what's right
heads bowed eyes closed
loving father in heaven
we thank you for this tough message it
was tough for the pulpit tough for the
pew
father
you have called us to be like you
to live in your image
that must apply to every situation in
life
in the name of jesus christ who humbled
himself even unto death the death of the
cross
give us a humble spirit
give us a spirit of self-sacrifice
self-renouncing love
that by giving in
which is being righteous
we may win those with whom we have
conflicts
by giving in we may save the church
save families save friendships save
businesses save societies
please god
help us to dwell on what we've heard and
as i said to seek the divine power only
divine power can enable us to do this to
seek divine power
to give him
accept on truth
that we may win
i offer this prayer from my heart
in jesus name
amen
you